I'm getting a drink
[Music]
alright man been a while
are we analyzed now I'd do it yeah
actually Bob you spawned right next to
me mark used to bond a little far away
but if you had a steel head does okay I
see the arrows should I gather on the
way there or should I not every time I
played this Patrick has been playing and
he's just like he's always got
everything like done so I never really
have to do anything early on we were
basically starting fresh together after
a long time mine wants me to make a
bedroll where do I get plant fibers from
just press e grass on the ground the
little grass you punch it rock wow I'm
punching the [ __ ] out of these plants do
we want it like I have a bedroll do we
want to like put it somewhere or not yet
and let me come to you guys guys mark
you coming hey I'm gathering up some
stuff on the way this good stuff this is
a meteor I found to be here I'm rich I'm
coming oh that's oh yeah there are
zombies in this but forgot about that
right zombies ah problem guys you uh you
in some sort of trouble there man I'm
fine they're slow they're slugs stupid
and I'm fast and smart you guys know
that about me everyone knows that about
me fastest now we didn't actually say
that
that's just fast smart mark hmm fast
smart Maher thinks honestly the first
time you said I think is it fat smart
mark everyone knows
all right I see buildings there's a full
jackal don't leave me to die we're
looking like right here pretty much
where we are don't abandon me which I
know you guys love to do we have not
moved since oh god if you leave me
behind I'll never let you forget it I
will roast you for the exact same spot
we started in
I will just I will haunt you if I turn
into a ghost look at this box I made you
I'm gonna help yourself by putting one
here 200 all right how do I do anything
gather some stuff mark I'm gonna make an
axe are you doing the tutorial no no no
yes no yes I made a bed roll flop yeah
place I'll grind them pick it back up
real quick and just to complete the
quest darn it I'm good in the sack even
the game knows now we have to journey to
a settlement where is the settlement in
wait yes yes mark tab then click on your
little character really buff I hit him
so buff you guys didn't tell me I'll
buff I was it's pretty cool man woah how
hard that tree just bit it I'm gonna
club this zombie get clapping oh well oh
I miss damn it what are you doing trying
to kill us he certainly seems to be
trying to do something how do I keep
missing missing what missing what joke's
on you didn't even feel it
you're gonna false this is design in my
head is there a spear in my head I don't
see it the sake only what it's here what
do you even repair how do you repair it
just throw it away and build a new one
how do you throw it away
drop it out of your inventory Oh easy
enough there anything of value in these
houses or oh there's a zombie zombie you
say those don't exist
I found scrap boots sir oh yeah just
metal blocks on my feet I'm so [ __ ]
hardcore guys hmm hey screw your head
did I get my arrows dude this zombies
invincible you need some help a real man
no no real man on the scene I'm bleeding
super profusely bandaged do not die I
thank you man
you got to squish the nog bro all right
sure we do should we do the thing go to
the place wait and no I need to do the
wooden block thing I haven't so honestly
we kind of need well it's the first
night should be that bad you needed ax
and then you right-click it with your
axe I just walked into it nice plank oh
oh Jesus Christ there's a bird killing
me hey bird oh my god well that it's
still after me
it's gonna kill me let's go to cover I
guarantee this is gonna kill me murder
it squishing I used my only bandage and
now I'm dying or something oh there's a
pig behind you watch out bum bum where
uh he looks pretty docile actually
should we go to the thing and get safe
bill don't kick you out so we can't stay
there we won't be safe at night there
well so do we need to just get a home I
get a home base situation
a prio subcostal preparing
we gotta build a place we can take over
this place and you start repairing it
you gotta crawl a zombie over here Wow I
took a lot of damage from you you suck
zombie how do we get more health stuff
there's a low around we need the aloe
plants that you see in the ground I got
some aloe let me get a cloth with the
fun claw I just need to cloth fragments
to make a bandage I have one Quan
fragment where do we get cloth check the
cars just find it or else you can tear
apart clothing I think and get it that
way like clothing that we craft clothing
or just general clothing just general
clothing you can just like find places I
think we should probably go inside
somewhere yeah yeah the running zombies
are not gonna be fun running zombies
there's a house right here we can go to
or else if you guys are close to one now
let's go back to wait and I'm just
officially started cleared the towel
Jesus Christ I wonder your arms you dick
there we go all right where are you wait
green on the on the compass agree Oh Oh
go inside oh god what is it bad it's
time all right going already one out
here if take care of all right oh damn
one swing nice yeah so nice beer baby
okay there's a big hole in the back yeah
we think they see light so torches our
arm is so dark in here I can't see
anything so we need wooden blocks right
I think we should go upstairs and just
fortify the stairs okay good and I can't
see anything so I'm gonna do a little
torchy oh wait up here I can see some
stuff there's a light up here
oh this beautiful man Oh God the floor
board I'll put a block there we need
some wood blocks how block should this
be I'm gonna put it fully blocked off
because like those vultures and stuff
they can fly in through oh god I'm gonna
part like ones on the stairs and just
sort of I'll try to get the ceiling all
closed off
yeah you write sped rules okay this is
actually kind of like I'm a little bit
like it definitely gets hard yeah I'm
actually gonna just build this floor out
I think I'm gonna take down this
handrails and make give us a little bit
more floor space I guess we get rid of
the pool table too right yeah would that
make too much noise I know more than
breaking the handrails are oh wow aha
was that see that painting I broke this
painting there's a hidden medicine in
their food supply bond it Oh interesting
this is fascinating it really beefed up
this game yeah oh I got a lot of rotting
flesh guys I don't know if you wanted
that I got bottled murky water out of
the toilet anybody wanna go god it's
very yellow
hey there's medicine in the medicine
cabinet here this vitamins painkillers
recog and fort bites I don't know what
those are
oh god that's that sound it's loud don't
sound good man done sound good I don't
see anything out the window so I'm
assuming that it's okay is there any
point to rotting flesh it might be like
emergency food like you could eat it if
you had nothing else I don't know I'm
gonna just go ahead and say we're gonna
get not that you can't stuff in this
game which you need like different
medicines antibiotics and stuff for
there's still stuff in the medicine
cabinet anybody wants it in the bathroom
okay oh we got someone's breaking in
that was me if you don't know there's a
zombie I hear the groaning okay they
quit running at four o'clock I think
7 o'clock 4 o'clock 7 o'clock 5 o'clock
oh they quit running eventually you're
on top of the stairs so oh yeah we can
like weave nice little archery spot here
we can try to hit them from so where are
they trying to break in supply I hear
them downstairs in the side
if you right-click like on the doors you
can fortify them if that doors now a
scrap door alright there's kind of
spooky wait till days up oh you can
totally get up on the roof over here if
we break some of these wooden things
down
the roofs nice except for you know
worried about vultures still well I
doubt we're gonna stay here oh yeah this
house is kind of [ __ ] but so can we I
carved the walls cuz I need wood yeah
whatever
Oh heard of record record Rekha that
sounds who's gonna toss die I don't
really care about die right now there's
is someone coming up the stairs or
something I I see I saw something on my
alert hey what's up the leaves
oh there you are oh my god I see you
through your hole
god I actually started me I never
noticed that we start with a note that's
like a threatening message from somebody
did you read the note that we start with
now you pay on time every time or there
will be constant huh is it day two
o'clock when do they stop yeah these
that mean for say 4 o'clock so it's 22
to 4 so it's 6 hours
I made night as short as I possibly
could for the sake of just not being
cooped up in the house yeah there's one
downstairs just going out a wall down
here well guys there's a sealed shipping
crate down here I don't believe you I've
got bottle of acid nitrate powder animal
fat and glue and glueck glue oh I just
got a grenade schematic nice I'm sure
you guys have level up points so if you
press tab and you click on the little
graduation cap skills
skill points right now there's dinner
Sam Suri's so it's like it says
attribute perception you click on the
bicep the fortitude all the different oh
my god oh my god oh my god he's a leaper
what what a leaper is that med I don't
remember fighting one of these before
[Applause]
and that and this
my god I want my arrow back squish him
in the face he's dead there's some more
zombies around here just to be clear
yeah he just like left through the sky I
thought it was like just a tumbleweed
good God a grandma scary
oh wait no this is a businessman
business grandma that kind of looks like
Ellen DeGeneres for a zombie doesn't it
oh yeah she'll back we just killed Ellen
Ellen that happens to the worst of us
why am i I was resting my back against
the worst of us though Ellen I'll just
stock up on the aloe for once we
eventually fire you need a band I'm not
gonna help you what do you need for
bandages besides aloe cloth drivers then
why don't you grab the medicine and
medicine cabinet no I can say I'm full
yeah we don't need the medicine we're
better than the medicine that's what I'm
saying that's what I've already said how
do how do i repair things wait how do
you do that so if you're if you click on
it in your inventory and you look like
top middle of your screen it'll say
modify repair scrap drop it does not
says craft or favorite note there it is
oh yeah
well that was easier than crafting a new
one well it's just like supply wise it's
not really that worth it early on
because the taxes are such [ __ ] so
there's a skill under the strengths
perks skill tree called path yield that
allows it open
if you guys want more carry space it's a
trick Bob don't listen to him it sounds
like a trick doesn't sound like the
thing I need yeah all right well I'm
gonna go looting now you guys enjoy not
having loot space and I'll seal it we
would be the worst in an actual box we
actually run into a cactus you think
we'd actually do that no but I would die
from some other thing you know it'd be
really annoying to be around Beautif I
was if I be apocalypse I'm turning into
a zombie like so fast and not by choice
it's just gonna happen uh are we
supposed to go find this settlement
trader person I mean that's the quest or
whatever but I'm not down to do what the
game tells me to do I'm down to do it I
want to are not a person for authority I
know that about you
we've already had this discussion we
have established this god yeah what are
you doing I had to fight for my life
Oh can you do a quieter there's a blank
one door with my ax one time and all the
zombies were like oh my god I fell down
to the inside guys I might be about to
die don't I'm on 18 health I'm seventeen
health I'm bleeding I appear to be done
right no no you lose you're only on five
health when I fix this I will try to
make you bandages and bring them to you
where are you will stop bleeding I'm at
five health the blandest baby stops
bleeding the aloe bandage star will heal
you a bit I don't even have a lobe
bandage on my recipe ala cream wait okay
I'll cream and then aloe bandage I've
never made them so sure first day
advantage needs oh you need the
schematic for it really yeah just a
bandage is just bandage cream by itself
does something then let me look ala
cream
yeah ala cream it also stops bleeding
so just aloe by itself will be
can I make Allen crema you have a low
but I don't have the hello cream must be
where's that at no yeah search in the
search bar you got to do it individually
all right I'll I need two more aloe leaf
so I've got some with me it's not a lot
of health I found sleeping zombie who
attacked me from not that far away where
do you respond
oh god my bed sack okay well that's not
too bad so it's my pile of stuff still
there can I just go back still be there
oh wait it's the opposite of what you
said I lost everything in my belt but I
kept my image Oh God
wait what's going on out there birds
yeah birds aren't real come on man no
there goes my zombie oh wow how are you
hitting me from so far away
I don't like the zombies in this game
they hit me from a thousand miles away
and I can't hit that man less than
standing on them wait explain yourself
what is this [ __ ] yeah the game devs
called they're like we're trying to [ __ ]
mark and Bob over and I was like alright
good luck guys seems like they're doing
exclusively to Bob because I'm fine just
wait your time is coming
okay sure yeah just hold on you'll be
[ __ ] over this is bad place to be
I'm being [ __ ] right now if you did
tell me you told me and you were right
told me not to warn you so I guess I'm
next on the [ __ ] list
all right I'm complimentary so full I am
so slow I am so encumbered mmm maybe she
used the strength points huh well you
didn't tell me how that's true that's
true I literally could not have told you
any more than I did and tell us how
until after we had already spent our
fourth round of strength points yeah
exactly
oh so now you just upgrade the attribute
itself before you can upgrade further
uh-huh milk drinker I do love milk softy
fit oh yeah now we're talking oh wait I
needed to get the actual pack meal stuff
not just strength yes buddy you're gonna
be able to upgrade in that pack-mule so
mom's oh dude you don't understand how
slow I am right now
sounds like a new problem no mark these
guys no don't let me mark slow oh come
on I'm done quick
I'm speedy why don't you die you a-hole
all right well no need to be rude oh no
I'm marks low marks one stop calling it
marks lows not fair
everybody if you're playing a game you
get over encumbered just know your mark
slow I'm fast
markiplier slow get over encumbered as
you just I'm lightning fast I might be
the fastest youtuber I might be like the
tourmaline
your lightning fast or your mark slow no
no no you can go Mach one
Mark's low your other marker mark can't
be both that's what know it feels
accurate feels right why would that be
accurate
why don't mind don't make fun of my
vernacular now Wow
just working right to the room don't get
mark oh that's that's just that's too
far what that's too far
you should hear I say the word tutorial
apparently that's alert it's turtorial
tutorial tutorial where are we staying
tonight what time is it try this almost
no yeah
three minutes probably your take that's
not so great
all right where's that house set are you
guys goin by oh my god oh your bed icon
on the map should lead you back to the
house are we staying there again that's
private so your arms to him dude up real
slow
we know yeah you know what I'm mark slow
and I gotta go goddammit fine I'm gonna
get you guys back someday I'm gonna call
me catch up to us
oh you got um i'm wade slow he's I see
what you did there I'm Wade you're wait
I'm art I'm wait no no no no wait no no
no well I mean I wouldn't want to be
that because that's not handsome that's
what that is
the feelings yes yeah I did yeah I did
get you yes I've got some clothing for
you guys if you guys still need clothes
now I got a nice cool jacket I'm getting
aloe plants on my way home I'm gonna be
the lowest I'm gonna be just sticky when
I get there that's why there's no aloe
plants out here people way behind you
guys what do you mean I mean I know what
was fellow anywhere why I'm barely alive
I'm practically dead I need the aloe I
gotta rub it on myself so I don't pass
out
oh no there's aloe plants around this
cactus I don't know if I'm capable of
this
so how Bad's this night gonna be in
comparison should be somewhat similar
for still pretty early on in the game
I believe your level dictates the
difficulty except for on days that are
multiples of seven like 16 yes
specifically 16 but Bob you're pulling a
real team Bob dum doesn't like jokes
being made about me
okay I see how this is dirty and I
approve no I don't approve I don't
approve Wow is there a way to make like
a chest or Oh secure source chest yes
there is yes okay do that yeah then I'll
put all my stuff in it then no no it's
my stuff oh yeah thanks I appreciate you
guys I got a t-shirt I got a real life
adult
t-shirt out here I do not believe it
well I'll show you what I get well I'll
show you I'll show you a get back that's
how I always talk don't come on don't
come on man no I'm not gonna let you
know no no come on now I'm gonna give
you the business yeah don't be mean to
Bob I'm not yeah what are you doing to
me no I'm gonna give you the business
come on no this is booming you're gonna
boo me right in the biz hole [ __ ]
that's what you are 22 oh that that is
ominous hey welcome to my house uh what
the Freak was that no the sound the
zombies make when they start to come for
your soul my soul specifically yeah your
soul it's all about the souls as opposed
to the other participating how'd you
make that chest you gotta make sure them
yes search for it in your search bar I
searched for nothing
click through until you get to it that's
the plan don't chuckle like that you
stop it now Bob right next to you
there's some new shoes and new pants
mark here's some new pants for you new
pants oh wait guys you know what I got
this important well I was sure there's a
nice shirt for one of you two I got some
decoration hang on let me just have a
good look what I'm doing to brighten up
our home
oh my we're gonna have to water it and
take care of it a little bit okay
I'm ready for this guy's look at the
helmet that I found holy you look like
you're ready for oh my god I'm ready to
rip it too much leg you know you don't -
cooking pot so we can cook like meat and
stuff now and I got a cooking pot - hang
on cooking real I found a cooking grill
oh man we clean the bathtub guys we
really need to clean that storage chest
left it locked oh that's mine I don't
want anyone to touch my stuff okay okay
all right unlock locked guys
oh you're in there so these are our
current quest to go to the settlement
the casino tokens are the currency there
does anybody have a glue your chest has
five glues in it like um please may I go
for it behold my blunderbuss don't you
shoot me what does antibiotics look like
click no ammo
bottle of acid is that him yeah sure
bathroom medicine cabinet I don't want
to go in there that's terrifying killers
here I do not have any end about
for mites vitamins recog and painkillers
none of those antibiotics oh no that
doesn't sound good it's all it's gonna
be morning in five seconds
who's out here between a [ __ ] all right
I've got a new slue G hammer so that's
fun us what kind of Hammer slew G killer
hammer I don't know how to make it any
more clear anybody's trying to help me
or you find something the ones that
we're outside the house yeah I fell off
the roof accidentally and now I'm
fighting them off okay okay okay yeah be
right there be right there I'm blunder
Debus anyway oh my god chunga's is upon
me blunderbuss is a mungus give me those
arrows inside of them mark there's a
cacti in there careful I won't do I
wanted to shoot the cactus so bad we
want to do shooting a cactus is just
it's your thing man come on just not
like this man sometimes when you're mark
slow all you gotta do shoot a cactus oh
no not like this mark slow come on guys
that's funny cuz it's accurate hey
sledgehammer works way better for
breaking rocks who knew kind of whooshes
- whoosh whoosh I don't like the whoosh
that's annoying I don't like your face
it's annoying something else I left out
you sorry sorry ok alright ok
stupid face sorry sorry alright well you
can't just say sorry and then do it
again in this sorry mark I said sorry
like six times how serious do I need to
take this well I mean I feel like a
marginally more than you are
sounds like somebody needs to grow up
there there's got a blunderbuss with
your name on it you threatening ball
yeah yeah that's not cool dude
yeah
Bob what are you using not cool about it
it's not cool just like we're doing it's
not cool oh yeah mark it's not your cool
see how cool it's not your cool not like
it's not you alright so just the main
thing about this game just sort of try
and survive
I barely make over the nine days to die
because of night seven okay so it gets
real sure sure so what wait but wait
what are we working towards here should
we go to the settlement settlement we
get side quit I mean it's a survival
game ultimately you build up Charlie
yeah there's not like a main story that
I know of it's it's about surviving and
[ __ ] gets harder each night starts to
get harder and eventually you're gonna
have to be built up or else you're gonna
get your ass kicked on night 7 if we're
still playing where we're at right now
we will die you need to gather supplies
when you get guns we need to build spike
like couple halls at most this guy this
guy's really being mark slow over there
sky 3 is he's cranking up the mark the
market to Dan a little looser what an
absolute mark mark asaurus rex oh is
that me he's - mark slow to get it
doesn't feel good to be called March
slow we call me something else well
you're certainly not Wade handsome right
now that's for sure
why am I breaking rocks rocks right now
rocks you got rocks coming in on the
rock road I have a lot of well what's a
lot of wood because I have a hundred 99
Wood is that a lot of wood
no that good wood we need like hundreds
of wooden spike traps because of those I
don't like 20h right approximately maybe
we need maybe you're the one looking or
whatever I'm not looking right now I'm
fortify the house this is excuses I'm
hearing excuse it is coming from that
anyone want 40 arrows cuz I'm about to
make them dude
I will be our Archer master I miss a lot
so don't rely on me for anything but I'm
here - I'm here to shoot arrows and
stuff trust me you got it
Wade these rocks don't seem so useless
anymore now that I'm making arrows huh
no I like your rocks mark turns out
you're not as mark slow as we thought
you were we should start killing the
chickens and pigs like me to get meat I
got eggs if you guys get eggs save the
eggs combining eggs and meat is a good
meal really well I mean in generally
unsuitable protein heavy enjoy but I
guess anything about this game dude no I
never recommend a game for us to play
unless I know it's gonna be fun and
quality content I don't understand why
you're what you've let us you know it me
neither
basically just hammering wood I mean
acting wood I don't know doing something
to it you're repairing the water you're
taking the wood I'm whacking it and it's
disappearing so I'm assuming that's good
are you guys not enjoying yourselves I'm
really kind of man I'm just that's what
I do I like the whole resource gathering
think it's my jam and game
I'm all about that oh oh well this nurse
is getting it
oh this nurses watching me murder this
nurse right now no I'm murdering my own
nurse oh we're both murdering nurses not
doing this yeah I was I was earlier I
was telling everyone they should be
grateful to their health care workers
but it was just a roost
I've actually hear from nurse murder
therefore it was a Charlotte Russe it
often is those in defense that are the
worst roost was just a big old chicken
and egg problem if you know what I mean
I do yeah that's what they call you some
people probably do call me beep Channel
I think credit for inventing the name I
did when I walked in our college dorm
room and you're like that's big sauce
right so that first phone call where we
ever spoke when we decided I had next
box than you had a TV yeah I called you
up and you were like oh I'm gonna be
calling you big sausage markiplier yeah
no she's naked I'm sorry chat that is
does boobs what are you doing what are
you guys doing I'm good
well you guys got the nurses I got the
nudists does this bloaty fellow explode
the way it looks like he might if I let
him get near me I don't know what
experiences you guys are having but it's
vastly different than them
very different than my own don't care if
you're talking you're getting the naked
people you're getting the doggies what
is shared XP I get big bursts of
experience whatever we can kill the
congas we good we eat share the X B so
if Bob kills something and you're close
then you get something extra like killed
I kill a honking jungus just then Daniel
you came at me like what blob and I was
like there might be a fox I don't know
you killed you killed a Rick and Morty
fan Wubba lubba dub dub
yes well beloved of do me
there's no copy left there's nothing
left I'm gonna feast on its corpse I
don't know if that's a good thing to do
either
I need like so many more rocks right now
I can give you yeah swing
I see you over in the horizon I'm gonna
do coming back to the house I'm
literally right now I'm literally next
to you I'll I'll be back don't you worry
about it I'm on top of you I'm gonna
drop a giant pile of arrows dude do you
have any oh snap there you go look at
this guy who the hook ups I'm like weed
delivery I just swing by drop off and
you're happy I'm about to blunderbuss
this guy that was the juiciest thing
I've heard all day
oh I arrowed is leg up I think I picked
up a quad damaged somewhere I am just
wrecking everything so what does the
eating youkai do
I don't I have a bunch and I've eaten it
stamina you can make a yucca tea or
something like that I think yeah um do
you guys know if you click tab you go to
your character where you equip the items
that on the left there's like a little
like bar graph you click on it shows
your stats of your health your hunger
and all that stuff I'm not gonna look at
that
apparently you Co supposed to be mixed
with water to make better water Oh yucca
juice not only is it chock full of
antioxidants it's also got some great
ginger esque qualities if you know what
I mean you know ginger
yeah is he feeling at the base of your
rod yes we'll get you there almost
exactly the same way but mentally
friendly you know what I mean I was
hoping for something like that 300 would
only equates to 16 spike traps that's
rude dog and have 574 wood is that
enough
I have 492 one of those numbers is
enough well I have more than both of you
so I feel like I'm the real winner here
you get to decide if it's enough you
have attacked by a vulture is that bad
yes I killed it I killed it why are you
on the mountain zombie stupid idiot why
did it idiot fro I'm not here to judge
anyone you know peace and love but what
an idiot bro I don't know what I started
with fantastic
Wade you've done this shimmying towards
me at an alarming rate sir I do not want
any of your girls your dogs Girl Scout
cookies sir sir I tried to tell you I'm
not interested in your daughters
daughters cookies I can't even say the
word daughter man I did not get far we
need this to be like three layers deep
well we have a couple days right how do
we need this to be so deep a couple days
but you know bro I can get you some
what's that stuff people go in the
desert and do [ __ ] dive get buried
the drug stuff rasca bro I'm gonna get
us some ayahuasca the hell is a circle
around a campfire we're gonna get so
deep I first thought the business to
hide a body
what the [ __ ] we talking about
wait come on now I don't think about the
drugs I just thinking about murder
Stevens I guess this construction worker
is not happy
no the construction workers are
douchebags they're just like blammo
daughters Girl Scout cookies and you got
to just be real forceful with them I
need to get home guys guys guys farther
than I was home oh I'm all right it's
actually nighttime oh goodness me
nighttime boys oh my god I'm getting
attacked by an [ __ ] bird I'm in life
you [ __ ] bird where are you guys lots
of wood so if you want me to get there
trust me don't leave don't leave the boy
wood in my chest
I'm almost we have an open window right
here what oh I'm out of steam this okay
oh I didn't know come on in
hey friends how's it going
should I lock the should I lock the
exterior doors they don't open them do
they I don't know
wait how do i unlock a door I locked you
really locked the door at the top I
think because we're all in the same
party we can unlock that someone here is
[ __ ] good come on guys keep it together
we want a lot of spike traps but we also
still need to be working on making sure
there's not holes in the house like that
one right there
should make a few frames frames
maybe frames someone confirms does
anyone have any leather did anyone
manage to kill like a pig or something
and how do we make something to forge
iron we have to make an actual Forge
which I think there might be a skill
tree for that I don't know there's a
skill underneath intellect called
advanced engineering I think we need to
buy advanced engineering the blacksmith
perk oh you right I can buy that craft
forges yeah okay cool so I don't know
what the Forge recipe is clay soil small
stone leather 10 leather 10 all right
follow boy I'm gonna level my intellect
so I can make better healing stuff I've
gotta keep taking a lot of damage for
some reason I don't know what's
happening are you like dysentery tore
poisoned or something I have 9.7%
infection right now and I have no access
antibiotics good I know it's not quite
defined going about did you go in the
medicine cabinet in here there are no
antibiotics in there
what about fort bites like I don't want
to recog you just sort of things that
are in there but I find none of those
are antibiotics anybody exits a very
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like you're a rejected Muppet on
guys I have herbal antibiotics in my
inventory whoa
all right now I have no infection
anymore or whatever that means what the
hell does that mean
now I have happy infection 9.9% what the
hell does that mean your infection is
smiling bright I have an old sham
sandwich well that gives me 12% food
poisoning that doesn't seem good yeah
I've got us so over here if you guys
come back over here where I'm at I will
not why would I do that I put a camp
fire that has all the necessary things
for cooking
[Laughter]
[Music]